WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, Google.
What's the temperature
like at Mount Everest?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: The
temperature there is minus 14.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Ooh,
I better pack a jacket.
Oh, hi.
I'm Wayne Piekarski.
And today, I'm going to talk
about the Google Assistant
and how you can develop
your own actions to be
a part of this new ecosystem.
At Google, we've been
providing assistance
to users for years across
many of our products.
But we think
there's much more we
can do to help people get things
done right when they need it
in a conversational way.
And that's why we're building
the Google Assistant.
The Google Assistant
can help users
get things done
throughout their day,
whether they're at
home or on the go.
And it powers devices
like, for example,
the Google Home, a
voice-activated speaker.
To better serve user
requests, the Google Assistant
needs to work well with
an ecosystem of everyone's
favorite services.
Actions on Google allows
you as a developer
to integrate your services
with the Google Assistant.
And that is what
we're going to explain
how to do in this video.
Conversation actions enable you
to fulfill a user's requests
directly via two-way dialogue.
Users don't need to
pre-enable skills
or install new apps to interact
with any actions you build.
When a user asks for
your action by name,
we'll connect them
with you immediately.
Let's first go through
a detailed example
of a user interacting with
a conversation action.
Think about something as simple
as helping a user choose what
to have for dinner based on
their mood and the ingredients
they have around.
Let's call this
action Personal Chef.
The user first needs to invoke
your action with something
like, OK, Google, let me
talk to Personal Chef.
The assistant will then
introduce your action.
And now the user is
talking to you directly.
>From this point onwards, you
get to interact with the user
and have a conversation.
OK, Google.
Let me talk to Personal Chef.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure,
here's Personal Chef.
PERSONAL CHEF: Hi, I'm
your Personal Chef.
What are you in the mood for?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Well,
it's kind of cold outside,
so I'd like something to
warm me up, like a hot soup.
And I want it fast.
PERSONAL CHEF: All right.
What protein would
you like to use?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I have
some chicken and also
some canned tomatoes.
PERSONAL CHEF: OK.
Well, I think you should
try the chicken tomato soup
recipe I found on example.com.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hmm,
sounds good to me.
So this is a pretty
rich interaction.
Think about all the
sentences I spoke
and how the action
needs to extract
the meaning out of this.
How would you implement this?
If you're an expert in the area
of natural language processing,
you can use the
Conversation API,
which allows you to process
the raw strings that contain
the spoken text from the user.
You can then use
the Actions SDK that
includes all the tools
and libraries you
need to build the actions.
However, if you don't want to
process the users transcribed
speech yourself, you can
use one of the tools that
have integrated with
Actions on Google.
One of these tools
is api.ai, which
provides an intuitive
graphical user interface
to create conversational
interfaces
and it does the heavy
lifting in terms
of managing conversational
state and filling out
slots and forms.
This means you'll no longer
need to process the raw strings.
api.ai can do this for you.
To handle a conversation, use
the api.ai Developer Console
to create an intent.
This is where you
define the information
you need from the user.
For our example, finding
a kitchen recipe,
this would be the type
of food, the ingredients,
the temperature, and
the cooking time.
You then specify
example sentences.
api.ai parses these
sentences and uses
them to train its
machine-learning algorithm
to process other possible
sentences from your users.
You don't have to write regular
expressions or a parser.
You can also manually set
what the acceptable values are
for each piece of information.
Once this is done, api.ai
uses these definitions
to extract meaning out
of spoken sentences.
The user can provide information
naturally, out of order, all
at once, or in pieces.
The action can ask follow-up
questions as needed.
Pretty neat, right?
Once you've set up everything
in the api.ai console,
you can then test it
all out immediately
with example sentences.
Then you can test your project
with the web simulator,
preview it on Google Home,
or deploy the full project
to Google, all
from within api.ai.
Next, you can connect
up an optional web hook
to your intent to
allow it to interact
with a back-end server.
When all the details
you need are filled in,
your web hook is called with
the appropriate details provided
as JSON data.
You don't need to worry about
parsing strings or dealing
with responding
back with follow-up
questions for the user.
You can also develop the
web hook using the language
and hosting platform
of your choice.
It's just an HTTP callback.
So api.ai makes
this really simple.
It's easy to get
started, and you
can have a prototype working
in just a few minutes.
You should check out
our screencast video
where we show all of the
steps to make this happen.
So the Google Assistant is
the next big opportunity
for developers.
By developing Actions
on Google, you'll
get cutting-edge experience in
natural conversation interfaces
and be ready to actively
participate in the emerging
space of AI first computing.
In addition, you'll be able
to help shape the platform
and grow your audience in all
the devices and contexts where
the assistant will be
available in the future.
And thanks to conversational
interface building tools
like api.ai, as well as
Google's unique understanding
of the user's
interests and context,
you'll be able to
create frictionless,
intelligent experiences
for people that engage
with the Google Assistant.
You can find out more about
Actions on Google by reading
the documentation at
developers.google.com/actions.
We also have an Actions on
Google developer community
on Google+ so you can ask
questions and share your ideas
with everyone.
We look forward to
seeing what you build.
And I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]